all right and we are laughs welcome I
opt math we doing on intro be drunk we
have packs we gonna set this off now you
gotta laugh about you know so we got the
coal from the coal most all in the
building not at pass was below shot come
on brother
boy how you doing sir right to the
bushes III came Bailey what's going on
yes can't like he's really distorted
sound let's go you watch the lower down
here I think all yours is drunk and of
course we get the more technical game
and so on my brother Louis sovereign I'm
doing sir chillin man
chillin I have a face as you can see
incredible
[Music]
and the Lord really makes appearances
what has blessed us with his presence
taking on the moon and your favorite
Lord came back soon
what's going on sir hey I'm chillin I'm
feeling nice I got called into service
for the I owe you for this weekend I'm
happy for it s was man with that see
more of you on cam I'm like in this face
except King Austin situation is right
now
he's in the bushes right now he can't
talk to you but what I'm gonna do they
got him they garden in the back of one
of those servers that he hates inside
and last but not least he's muted right
now and quarantine will see the young
lord of the stream team
my main MJ is a boss but he's muted so
we'll see if he'll talk afterwards he
does exist you know but I know that we
don't get right into it it's gonna be a
short little thing Charlie King for
coming up with an idea you know how to
be busy working is a lot of footage
going out here you know I'm saying we're
gonna plan to go out there but you know
in the meantime you know you see nothing
working so let's bring it to the panel
you know I'm saying obviously adding it
is not at back he's gonna but you don't
saying he's been in the back row so you
don't start off with office I saw was
stalled
you know just your day one impressions
on tags what she's seeing him what's
your experience you know how you feeling
that was what's moving to shake it out
here around it was pretty good man first
thing we did when we came down the
escalators we ran into a boy in hip-hop
gamer and I always looked out for the
Lord he told us right into an interview
he was having with the developer of
control and that was just amazing the
first ten minutes in the room we camera
control looks absolutely amazing so then
we did that and then we went off to do
separate things and then you guys
managed to see some day's going stuff so
I wanna I'm excited here about that and
then a lot of time online what eating
your boxes events
oh boy then absolutely lost Kitty Shack
some city shake is little I know you
took it for the $1 super chair thank you
brother quality's not ever thank you
thank you thank you mother for the $1
someone's have much appreciated sir I
guess they're trying to do some kind of
dijanna gonna be interchangeable oh yeah
so continue solve anything else and
stand out you know yes but it's now this
is your first tax way I get to feel like
what I was what I liked is what exactly
what you guys were talking about all
year last year was the fact that it's
just a much more intimate show that 83
the devs out there on the stone floor
they want to talk to you they're more
than happy to explain you know sit there
with you 10 15 minutes and talk about
their game and it shines a spotlight on
the smaller games that we saw a game
called a new a new the distant like this
is a Metroidvania that looks absolutely
amazing is doing some different things
in the metroidvania genre and it's
developed by two guys Oh they've been
offering it for five years basically so
there's a lot of cool stuff on the show
floor and it's just great to see
people's passion for but for what
they're doing and passion to see the
fans and talk to the fans
so taxis movie has it thumbs up for me
absolutely that is what's up no doubt
MJ's the boss are you back sir are there
like any young guns now this is your
prefer packs correct absolutely yes
metal you ever stuck expected if you
give the young voice and perspective man
like how you feeling out here what did
you feel
what are some standout for you as far as
things that you've seen in your first
gay experience effects first day
experience I've really enjoyed it I got
to go around and meet like new
developers of game
stuff like that mm-hm so if anybody's
everything about going to pack C's then
definitely recommend it I had a great
time you know now now me you've got a
good story in reference to days go on we
won't disclose photo obviously coming on
you and I'll see more like so now though
none Pam but all bloggers say like what
what did you feel cuz you got hands over
you playing a lot on yeah what what did
you feel when the game was really fun
but it was also really challenging game
[Music]
mode and crazy and it is how did the
bike car control I've seen a bike to it
I guess my little issue was a little bit
with her with the frame rate a little
where like I did feel a little
controller controls felt really good
actually I mean so overall that guy that
was experienced what was like the top
the top I don't know that's that's her
touch is very big go down low down all
right Lord Chi Matsu you aware that this
is I believe this is your first acts of
love there yes definitely my perspective
I'm definitely enjoying
it's a much more intimate experience
ending 3 mmm this is it cuz you've done
patching gun in three
so in your opinion tell people why pax
is a little bit more intimate why he
digging a little bit although I'm still
a little worried because I was talking
with more King about this and he was
telling me that when it comes to
Saturday that's when they get shoulder
the shoulder impact and you can't really
move around by simply the first day be
able to go around you saw a lot of
people displaying their wares but I mean
the nd love when it comes to packs just
beautiful for you see everyone has
everything posted up up there you go
talk to the devs
they'll give you a breakdown of what
their game it is
and then you know when you're playing
like if this ain't be confusing about
controls they'll go up to you and
they'll go hand by hand I mean the
certain games that I played the lot I
played with today also up with that
experience it just made it better and
made me excited for a lot of games that
I played
especially for a job no doubt no doubt
and of course I want to get in more
smelled OPD pushes standouts man would
you like theirs they have a lot of games
out and they I could see that a lot of
the you know those triple-a titles and
high-end guys there's not many of those
titles around and it's gonna be really
interesting to see what is going to you
know what the rest of the B titles that
we're going to see this weekend that
we're going to talk to because the all
those those Triple A titles or we're not
really talking to anymore so it's gonna
be nice to see what the rest of
everyone's gonna be able to bring to the
table because that that's what I'm or I
like to envision and see more is those
indie boots because the new boots are
are there so many and those guys are
probably more passionate about their
games because you know it's there
there's so I'd love to see that and I
would love to see those the others that
are you know the ones that have had
those big publishers but they're not the
super big publishers like when we see
digital devolver and it's gonna be
really nice it's gonna be really nice to
see those guys no doubt know I did King
I am dying to hear your impressions you
had a lot to say during the gearbox
conference as well as other experiences
so let's get to a king I feel about the
tax day one what you feeling what you
cannot do them here's the rule first of
all call me shank all right a little
shake you understand me all right what I
would like to say is you know a lot of
dudes Arthur Ford told me Buckingham you
know stuff like the out here we all here
so we go saw so gearbox kita started
they had the banging music the music was
banging like so they stopped the video
and the video did start although oh boy
oh boy this is not going good so they
had that day day day and also up there
he was tearing it up he gave you the
presentation it was beautiful so
everybody was there for their gearbox
you know for the borderland three shout
out to borderland three-phase ha yeah
you know say cuz you ain't got this cuz
you can't talk about so stop it alright
they gave us a call for games
so my fault the presentation because old
boy saved it he did a hundred percent I
can do that trick and the trick is crazy
so shout out to him for doing the magic
I can't do right then we got down to the
floor and like I said a shout out to UM
kingdom comes deliverance for the new
dlc that's coming out
diversity inside the new dlc where you
take care all overhaul win and you get a
dog oh my god discuss some aspects of
the game they take the game up to a
thousand percent then what game is stood
out from me i'm have to say samurai
shodown because it was a brokeback for
all me lord sovereign a local pastor
we've got video of all three of us
playing the game there's wonderful was a
beautiful game i know the input lag at
this point in time called me a little
concern i didn't know who was either the
controller or the system that we've
known at the time i don't know but um
hopefully that can be corrected and we
can definitely get it all great game but
that's a day one purchase on my part as
far as packs goals like i said there's
more intimate I'm so happy that you get
a chance to see the devil you get a
chance to put a face to the game you get
a chance to all schedule all the
appointments with these doves that are
eager to talk about their wares I love
the way packs is it's a whole different
beast than III yeah man I gotta agree on
the jump impact I've always said I wanna
shout out in front of we get to choose
the leak out
you don't say shout out you know Sam but
on like packs is like like you said it's
more into me get morning it's all stuff
like that you know I'm saying so shout
them data voice we definitely rocked
that day's going out you know definitely
a highlight for me so far he's
definitely in Florida alone and it's
definitely a different product and how
it first was our own I don't be an
actual that behind the scenes like III
2017 and it's different now you know I'm
saying definitely cinematic it's all
about the bike is all about getting you
know I'm saying whatever they got to get
in so I like that um a couple of
standouts for the show I like that game
sob was playing what was that I call it
Jon Snow the game was French economist
from THQ Nordic that game
looked amazing it is a survival game has
all the it implements all the things you
expect out of a survival sort of sim
game but it's a third-person action game
and the protagonist looks exactly like
Jon Snow so it all began there's a
beautiful yeah it's a it's a
single-player co-op game the game looks
absolutely beautiful it's called faint
to silence THQ Nordic a stone bangers
come in serious bangers bio mutant is
well looked absolutely insane in it so
we got we don't we go I had to hit that
Phu Nordic diamond absolutely no
challenge of these issues shake pushes
focus right now like let's keep good at
eh keen order because they make an 80%
of the game surely like well what kind
of presents did borderland time it was
epic first of all the Lion King but we
gain no more don't ya man like the
gearbox being like like I said the
energy was intense that the fans are so
feeble to pitch I mean they had a lot of
announcements you know I've seen a lot
of other cult favorite kind of games
that they kind of announced cause cut
was the name of that game that you like
that side game that was kind of like I
guess a sequel to long allegedly Wayne -
yeah everything - yeah yeah
look at it thing is the original game
for the risk of rain basically it was a
very long lunar shooter typo
like it they tried to do kind of like
the borderlines thing where you get like
different weapons and whatnot
although but it was completely pixelated
the new game is 3d although what going
going back to its in these roots it
wasn't like this is a it wasn't the the
most beautiful ballad tonight
well I got a guy I'm good no but I was
gonna say with that well at the same
time what they announced over as give my
presentation was that they were actually
like it was like a public beta so
nobody's paying for yet anyway so I'm
looking forward to downloading and see
how it is so I want a shout out so
obviously you know everybody around pop
see this week social media then go an
email border Wow it'd be a very
disrespectful
okay can I get the birth little Lord
shank is trying to Borderlands and like
I said the feedback wasn't too good now
we're within right and the Lord's gonna
speak on this MJ right after that goal
which is look you know shout out the
ready
pitchfork he's trying to make it happen
you know did a little magic trick that
man went on a note to roll but Danny got
to the main crescendo of all instability
and you know it's epic everything
everyone's hype the crowd Eva pitch they
drop it and the video footages buffering
and framing and doing all type of
craziness so I don't know that's not the
game I'm say I know this is a packed
each issue there if they can't take care
of what it is let me try to run it again
and it's just one of those things that
in the moment make personality even if
it wasn't offering people before but
I've never seen a crowd go so crazy but
choppy footage in my life there were you
know there they were face in the
auditorium
right it was it was people sharing it
was insane what was going on for boy
lands brief but I guess because of them
playing in and you know they kind of
lost a little time in it in my opinion
and then the last thing is I'm gonna
keep it all the way 100 like I'm late to
the ball dancers is really cool but it
kind of did look more of the same
I'm gonna get it I'm gonna enjoy it I
like it you know saying but I could
understand something but so I'm gonna
give it a feeding them to actually begin
with everything like to laughing hope
yeah what's your thought like does that
make the moment she was killed by a
whole new technical difficulties for you
were still in the moment you step on the
stage
panting the game in front of all those
people live sharing yeah but everything
thanks what about tree P like what you
really would you cringe in well coming
coming from my IT background I'm sitting
there going why didn't nobody test this
before that was my number one because no
matter what what happens during any any
presentations I have I say you have
video let's run the video let's make
sure it's working and then to see them
having those problems I was just like
number one they didn't test that no and
I had to Ben we don't have time for it
just go so that was one I will say the
I'm blanking on his name right now the
CEO that guy was professional he was
professional he was amazing as a
presenter and for him to do all the
things he did pretty much on the fly I
gave and I give that guy you can tell
how much he loves his calm
that he works with absolutely I really
you could tell that he loves the
employees he works with two because they
tried to play it once and it was choppy
everyone just dealt with it then the
second time that they were doing it it
happened again and he was pretty much
like no you used three thousand people
four thousand people whatever in this
room you're gonna stay here you're gonna
wait until it's done right this is these
people let me tell you something first I
was a little disheartened when the video
kept stopping I thought they were
playing out on the switch so I was like
oh man dragged the resolution baby if
you drop the resolution then you can
actually play but what happened was it
was the screen in the middle the screen
in the middle was a sink with the
screens on a soccer the screen in the
middle was for cake so after he decided
to dead the screen in the middle the
video play flawlessly and half they
played flawlessly I saw his vision and
then I said this man this man right here
he understood his convictions in his
story he stood by his team he didn't let
his team down that's what you talk about
a team leader so 100% I got a CEO listen
it easily fell into the bit was trying
to get into the bushes no action for
names three but people praised this game
really hard you two demographic part of
a crackdown to me and similar art style
gets trash I don't get it oh they go
down the drain
thank you yeah yeah
a valid point Devin and what I'm gonna
say is I did say I did see anything
different different I shout out to the
Lord the packaging was dull and that
grandfather bought amazed so he is back
the og Lord saw what do you how did you
feel about the moment the moment was
cool man I got to give it to Randy
Pitchford man he saved it like honestly
the man did not lose his cool when the
first video started chopping up and
wouldn't play at all he brought out the
team to sort of highlight all the points
that were gonna be in the remaster of
Borderlands 1 um and then again when it
happened with the with the borderlands 3
video he said no we're gonna play it
again
and when it froze the second time he
said no we're gonna play it yeah and you
know he didn't he didn't get flustered
he could have easily gotten pissed off
and he really didn't yeah set out to him
he really saved it now in terms of the
game honestly I'm late to the
Borderlands party as well it never
really appealed to me but that said if
you're aboard a Borderlands fan and you
just wanted more Borderlands I think
that's what you're gonna get
it's gonna be bigger it's gonna be
smoother it's gonna be prettier I think
the environments are gonna be bigger but
it's it's just more Borderlands and I
and I guess that's what the faithful
wanted so I think that's what you're
gonna get but the Mormon same cool man
the people that were really into it they
really loved that boy
even with the chop heat with the choppy
video they stood up and clapped they
were happy so it was a good woman to be
a part of absolutely absolutely
Nord kind Matsu what did you say it was
the moment loss was it trash was it
overweight like oh no I actually respect
the event and it's actually on the fans
over there they really got everything
hype moments as for the magic trick I
was like no one let me look at my phone
into it stuff but I I respect Brandi
Pitchford or a lot of things he's done
this past there's one thing with him
he's a king of being straight up
straight up anyone who's ever dealt with
um when he had that situation where he
was getting into lawsuit did you a me
over I believe all time a Christians and
then basically here when it comes down
to him he'll give you a straight-up
answer and he definitely did saved
perform he did really save the person
presentation for everyone involved as
for the actual Borderlands reveal and
also and then listen to make this
cleared so the frame rate had nothing to
do with the actual game down with the
actual video I'm glad that narrative
hasn't really shown up on Twitter which
I really expected but the only thing I
do see when it came to the Borderlands
reveal is that it does look like more
the same so it's like until I so I can
see actual gameplay which I thought they
did actually were going to show is like
I don't have to reserve my judgment but
I mean it's gonna be good to have
another player Plus this is after
destinies to come out so I'm I'm I'm
interested to see if they'll take any of
that into account with the kind games of
service my everything yeah alright no
doubt I'm gonna get with the PD I want
to do some fun alright what was trash to
you at PAX so far what did you look at
what's children it was trash what you
didn't like
are you talking about the last game that
we know I know you know what yeah I
don't think that game was trash let me
say let me say this I'm say this I'm a
satyr games alright like really complete
a lot of those games heart ready so
these people are all every last person
is out there being fearless showing
these games so I really I don't really
think that this should be done that's
math you know listen Baudelaire put
herself out there to be scrutinized I
checked right what I would say when it
comes to borderlands they did it
recovery they did a backflip hop step
and they grab their legs and he stood up
straight so he can't [ __ ] on borderlands
anybody out there give him borderland
slander he was known by it anyways -
shut up
that was looking at choppy video didn't
care how he was getting it there was
they granted that they was feeling for
that so there is a market for those
people these people dressed up then
fever curse they made they costumes they
out there they're supporting the game so
they're gonna get the game the game's
lost sell millions I don't care what
y'all saying and if you matter here are
you talking about something please stop
it just stop wash your ass that's it
that's the only thing that was trash
everything else is great the macaroni
and cheese
a pizza check MJ what part about packs
was trashed Julie nice to avoid when
we're playing that one fighting game
Monday these so much worse yeah Thursday
is the light day
you know you miss media to get people
but Friday is that day if you got the
old level was what it was
you have not seen getting today to the
food you're not encounter Friday and
Saturday straight up you know when you
saw us on the IOP shirts with the
built-in excuse me shank was saying was
there now a lot of these elements to be
really telling you very fierce show on
some games are being shown is very
Hurley building really don't have we
don't to do that I will say the only
thing under the planet areas not know be
completed I gotta keep it real that's
Boris video I wanted a little bit more
like last year yet on speed indicate I
had been played by that time we had big
scene number debut kind of gang I think
we saw all MJ a piece or shadowed the
Tomb Raider we saw four lives in here
because so yeah like dings we'll have a
couple of offers that you haven't got a
chance to Nintendo's out yet
hey I got talking about Mortal Kombat
for the next patch at we won't talk
about that but on I just hope to the
point I guess it looks like getting
really you're my opinion here enough
equally and the presence at practically
what I was expecting
as in Paris key the lash what would you
guys be yeah I think they just packed it
hmm its downsized missed a lot of things
that they didn't show and I was very
surprised picture blaze never seen
Triple A is it I've seen probably like
one or two I was surprised when I saw
days gone be honest with you but again I
don't think Sony looks at that as a
triple-a title to be honest with you so
I've never really seen Triple A titles
here I mean it's a Borderlands yeah but
they took a whole convention hall
upstairs to debut they stuff they
actually separated a cell from the
showroom floor so really this is all
about the little man and a little man is
shine through I love what the little man
is doing and it's just so much that we
got a cover we got to see so what about
like excite like the stuff that you
cover specifically like what got you
right if you can't you know but ain't
great for people to see I'm Samurai
Shodown to me was was huge because it
psyched that I'm King and I know like
the hours that we spent on that game we
bought everywhere than that again King
bought King both the $200 SNK you know
the the Neo Geo version and then he
bought the CD version then we played
then we flavoured at the Neo Geo 64
birds in downtown it's at Chinatown
figure the people in Thunderbirds and we
had the UM the genesis version yeah
version 10 where I just go down under
the Sun and so to see that game come
back as beautiful as it is the animating
the way it does like that was that was a
beautiful thing to see it and that game
face of silence was absolutely fantastic
because for the most part when you think
about a survival game you're thinking
about something how maybe in an overhead
perspective a first-person perspective
you don't really think about it as a
third-person action game and when you
look at this game it looks like a
third-person action game it looks like a
game of Thrones game to be honest it
looks like you're playing as Jon Snow
and so the fact that they kind of
incorporated those two genres together
is very cool so that game just want to
look out for and it's only a couple of
weeks out
it's three weeks out no I mean actually
but I think that game is he three weeks
out to actually being official release
though and efficient when I think it's
already is already looking beta right
it's an early access on Steam on believe
yeah Lord shake any standout what a you
personally covered okay what was the
game that he said uh the the more you
attack the the more energy you get that
was in control right so control talk to
me more because when you say that they
reward you for being an aggressive play
style type of game I'm not an aggressive
play style type of gamer so he said
you're not gonna heal by hiding behind a
corner waiting for your energy bar to go
up if you're not actively out there
trying to defeat and destroy a situation
you're not gonna get your energy back so
it's to hide his futile that resonated
with me watching the physics in the game
resonated with me the fact that um I
like quantum break so much I felt that
is a natural progression to the title
and to switch it up and to change lanes
would I know they don't want to be
bundled in with quantum break and they
want to be a standalone title with
control but I do say there's some
similarities to it but that to take to
say that I will be rewarded for being
aggressive I'm definitely buying a game
alright shout out to the show furthest
out to hip hop like you literally walk
in a pack
he's with the controlled area and we
walked in and he's like oh they go to I
roll with grab them all we're in his
interview like it was did the foot is
gonna be late yeah I'm gonna see when
that go up absolutely hilarious okay
like guy was super passionate bike
instead control of super promising demo
three more of an extension of quantum
break so I gotta agree with that man
whoever's broke yet as far as like
personal you know stand out for that
hold left he got it is get you we got
you pay MJ did we get you
trying to think my favorite thing was
probably was that one game that we
played words like you'd sneak home or
something like there yeah they got some
really cool games of very stealth for
candy and he had a second game was kind
of like in the Nazi era but that first
game yet it was kind of like yeah yeah
you were doing to sneak in and I was
like this is like Assassin's Creed which
are like a little kid Charlie leave a
monastery yes this is awesome and it was
a Greek concept and you think would have
been worse can we can we say I'm gonna
stay off the Rick can we say you really
like this smashing unreal out here and
these games which might really these new
games is it me I felt the unity games
looking really strong no yeah I thought
I thought a lot of the unity games was
hold to hold on their own a lot more
than that he used to yeah before you
could see the difference but now I think
that people have been working with them
long enough that they're kind of
starting to make them develop into a
little bit of stronger roots for your
boss rules that we play Assassin's kid
okay not the same when I saw the beta
silence and that was when I played over
there basically like you said is a Jon
Snow game but I think I like personally
about it was that the survival aspects
that you really have to worry about
warmth you have to worry about stamina
and the actual gameplay itself is very
dark souls and I remember talking with
little bit Lord shank about this that
also they give you Q so if you're not
that good in Dark Souls games that they
haven't kind of like cues that you can
actually see that will kind of help you
out and then
and bring you in - yeah I can't wait to
see the footage on that ma'am that's all
we got
like I said a little small shot right
here for the Lord's a little small round
table you don't save just to give it to
y'all just all feel of a one tax cool
got together we got tons of coverage
that's coming anyway come from the video
some other things we want to upload we
get right back in the mix for the next
few days and just want to give you a
little piece you know saying because I
know like someone getting to get post as
my warning or anything else more shank
when we get out of here everyone yeah I
just want to reach out to Carl let y'all
know that we're really all here see this
smoke you know we got a question shout
out the slow-mo he said I love Paquette
did you get bored man's rule and a
handsome collection you don't know my mo
you pay for the King bro you're gonna
get out here though I would say this is
more than deal with the jabs and you
just getting hands-on with it you know
the sample but yeah we all I want to
show what its gonna be fun man so thanks
for rocking us we will get these out
rolls and get up out of here
so let's start from the backside and
front to the back side was going with
the young cream teeny
boss himself the day he's gone mom man
North MJ big podcast ready
[Music]
[Music]
for the games Lord P dat Ailsa know the
way glasses
Twitter's now though discord police in
it like normal
it's now there's our TVs Matt which you
know and also with the ILP switch so you
know we're doing it we're we're busting
on and always trying to keep everything
you know in the loop and I've been
posting as much as I can about things
we've been doing and and everything been
hashtagging packs ILP if you're if
you're looking for stuff that we've been
posting so that's all in there and yeah
it's been outs so far it's been an
eventful first day knowing hi absolutely
well and even more you guys behind me
too I also you can find me on next parts
or katsu also if you guys wanna gaming
discord I'm always different topics
going on we have a lot of things see
that's what's up you know you know and
of course Lord Sovereign Lord make me
fun sir Lords of ILP at Twitter being
sovereign FPS on Xbox Live and of course
Lords of gaming dotnet check us out
there and look out for all the videos
that we'll be uploading of interviews of
footage of new game stuff like that
that's coming soon so keep an eye out
for that stuff you already know and I
can't so I can whistles up this week so
what I want y'all to do is make sure
your life follow subscribe make sure you
go check out IOP on the youtube channel
of your head y'all know you're there
make sure you like follows
down at the bottom make sure that you go
to loads of game a.net make sure you
like follow subscribe over there make
sure you check out all the new videos
that's going to be uploaded there's
gonna be given to you we're gonna do pot
shots every day we out hit we're gonna
let you know what's going on in the show
room flow we're gonna let you know when
we talk to the devs we're gonna post up
all the videos for the hotfoot you can
only get here because we care tomorrow
[Music]
Lord Shane this is his idea so we gotta
get back to people and we give it to
y'all so I can get coverage we got tons
to recruit development we spawn I'll get
killing enemies I got some about killing
do you know your name you okay YouTube
em there's a boss alright pretty much
every new game
Lauren people on lo are cast who you
just become the ninja completely empty
of course P so now go it's gonna be May
Indian tomas now that we won't hit up
that on that 12-game contemporary it
joined only that it's come out the live
map with the that's from each quit
walking out and they said that we can
get our game on with them or all of us
could get one one big game going on so
yeah have been talking with them since
we left so yeah we got that don't ask a
thought it was good tomorrow games -
action - his name - Marino with hockey
in high water gave me and check us now
and everybody enjoy your Thursday
big money done and we had a bass